hey guys i'm ryan right crazy we're
gonna watch a trailer today for i think
it's called yeah woman in gold
it's a Ryan Reynolds Helen Mirren movie
I love Helen Mirren and I love Ryan
Reynolds and I have been wanting Ryan
Reynolds and Helen Mirren to collaborate
for the longest time they just go
together so well right okay
I love my own joke I think I'm so funny
anyway yeah I don't know what the [ __ ]
movies about your suddenly lawyer
how is he some letters I founded my
sister's belongings I need advice from
someone I could trust you
can't you just helped me on the side
there is no one on the side there's a
full-time job
how can you see out of those offices yes
she is my aunt I did painted my first of
pink square painting she was taken off
the wheels of our home by the knots
he since then she's been hanging in the
Belvedere gallery in Vienna now you'd
like to be reunited it's just you really
think the painting that ends up as a
freak magnet will ever leave Austria
it'd be a mistake not to take a look at
the plaster
we're either four hours really I wonder
buy perfume and Konya King duty-free
never thought I'd come back that's our
hope on my wedding night
half a Vienna was here this is all them
welcome to Vienna they're going to put
as many obstacles in your way as
possible they were going to try and find
a copy of your aunt's we'll hit a search
for the file of my own you know
still glitching the souls of fun this is
such a nice build your own company the
paint belongs to mrs. almonds family she
is the Mona Lisa of Austria we will
fight you till the end for something we
believe is ours
they destroyed my family they killed my
friends they forced me to abandon the
people at the pieces that I let them
humiliate again we're taking the
Austrian government the court kind of
this day
there's no way to go nowhere we didn't
come here to meet cake long you have
spotted me and closed the doors in my
face ladies and gentlemen this is a
moment in history
once the past has been protracted we
will not have come here in vain
people see a masterpiece bite one of
Austria's finest artists that I see a
picture of my own a woman who used to
talk to me about life we should be
reunited with what is rightfully ours
and you can't drive a little faster the
top lid on your doormat is minty that
looks good
looks really good wow I love how it's so
personal it really speaks to you you
know as far as your family justice
definitely it makes you really stand up
for what's right in your soul sometimes
it's like you do got it like defend
yourself man this is I love it it's very
symbolic the whole time that was joking
earlier but right Madeline Allen Mirren
look [ __ ] fantastic actually
and very believable absolutely like
everyone knows Helen Mirren is a great
actress Ryan Reynolds is it's weird with
like I'm on the internet a lot on these
movie sites and like so many people seem
to like not like Ryan Reynolds here's
the thing his earlier films were really
hit or miss I can either have a really
great one stand out or he'd be in
something totally forgettable I find
personally that as he gets older he's
getting better and better a believable
and he's being put in parts that are so
just like in your faces look at this guy
people forget of like sort of movie oh
you did this one movie called buried
where it was just him in a coffin for an
hour and a half and the whole movie took
place in that and it was gripping it's
like a one-man show and he is [ __ ]
amazing in it so to see him like getting
a role in a bigger film to really
showcase more dramatic work I'm excited
for him to be able to showcase that
because it the putting him in the
position to play off an Academy Award
winner I think it'll be a great
supporting role in this film like this
looks it looks really good it looks
looks like it'll tug at the heart
imagine because so much time has passed
that even with the statute of
limitations things get dropped things
get lost to the system there's a certain
limit at a time limit to where you can
really tackle and approach things and
imagine being so personally invested and
believe in that cause so much that you
really have that faith that you can
accomplish what you set out to do you
know like early on and the trailer is
showing like Ryan Reynolds in how
America
a complicated relationship but Danny
you'll see that they're gonna grow
closer together and I like I like a
story like that too that really does get
to you emotionally in the sense of like
it's cheesy when you talk about it buddy
but it's [ __ ] awesome when you see
people coming together and of a mission
to that birth for good because like that
piece of art is so monumental and means
so much it is about like you want to see
her win you know thing about especially
in today's technology that we have it
used to be the only way to see a really
great piece of art was to go to the
museum that could have been true when it
was originally taken however now you can
go online you can see it you can go by
prints of it you can you know there are
so many ways to access and see a
beautiful piece of art but that doesn't
mean it needs to be in a museum it you
know you can give it back to its
rightful owner
belongs in a museum I hope people say
that because it's one thing you must
hate Indiana Jones I've never seen it
what why did I give you the Indiana
Jones poster for cause I have it and I
you belong in a museum of devils anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
you can check out a list of me crazies
channel vlogs challenges sometimes I'm
on there you know enjoy yourself there I
know I know your cleavage shows a lot so
subscribe Randy's there's no way - I
didn't do it right now okay alright and
as far as shout outs Co gonna be
starting up shout outs again in the new
year so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shout outs where you say
something interesting then I shout you
out that's the exchange
you have to earn if there are my [ __ ]
respect you know who I am